-This is the first time
I´ve seen you since the Oscars.
Congratulations.
You have an Oscar.
-Thank you. Thanks.
-That´s so great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It´s so well-deserved.
Where -- Do you mind --
I´m assuming
you get asked this a lot.
But where do you keep it?
-My mom has it.
-That´s very sweet.
-Yes.
-Did she ask before she took it?
-No.
-Okay, gotcha.
-No, she did.
-Okay, nice.
So, do you have any --
So you didn´t want it
in your own home?
-No.
It felt a little strange.
But I have two things
in my apartment
that are related
to that kind of idea,
which is a Nickelodeon
Kids´ Choice Award,
which is an orange blimp
that is also a kaleidoscope.
-That´s fantastic.
-And my spelling-bee trophy
from the fourth grade.
I got first place
in the spelling bee.
-Wow! That´s really great.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
-Do you remember
your winning word?
-I was trying to think
about this for a little while.
And what I remember it to be --
I could be incorrect --
was a compound word,
which is "microfinance."
-Microfinance.
-Go ahead.
-M-I-C-R-O-F-I-N-A-N-C-E.
-And now I have to
give you my trophy.
-Yeah.
The way --
When you asked me to spell it --
And I don´t want
to sound like a jerk,
but that seems like
a super-easy word.
-It´s a super-easy word.
I think I was also
like 10 years old.
But, yeah, it was pretty easy.
It was a pretty easy word.
-I mean, what were people
going out on?
Like "mittens"?
[ Laughter ]
"Mittens" was before.
The guy who blew it.
-That Josh.
And "mittens."
He couldn´t handle it.
-Still can´t wear mittens.
He´s so upset.
-You know Josh.
-This is very exciting
that you got to work
with Billie Jean King because --
You actually
spent time with her.
And she was here last night,
and you guys went
to the U.S. Open together.
-We did.
-And here is a photo
of you guys
enjoying each other´s company,
it seems like, right here.
-Really enjoying
each other´s company.
-You seem very happy right here.
You´re enjoying her so much,
you want to obviously save it,
so you can enjoy her on the road
when she´s not with you.
But she said she´s a very hard
person to watch tennis with
because she can´t stop talking
about what she´s seeing.
-But I think that´s why
she´s a great person
to watch tennis with.
-I would think the same.
-And I think
I´ve mentioned this before,
but there is no one
on Billie Jean´s other side,
so it´s just me, and she does
live commentary the entire time.
-Oh, wow.
-Right in your ear.
-Really?
And you did not mind?
-I did not mind.
I was learning so much.
-Is she mostly happy
with what she´s seeing
or mostly not happy?
-It depends. She just --
Every emotion she´s having
goes in a live stream
with a bunch of facts
interspersed
of what´s actually happening.
-Does it ever go outside
of tennis, like, "I´m hungry"?
Does that ever happen?
-I think -- Yeah,
I mean, she´s enthusiastic.
-She´s just running everything.
-Yeah. It´s all coming through.
-And she´s very enthusiastic.
I found her very inspiring.
We were talking backstage.
In our green room,
Billie Jean King was just --
Anybody who walked by her,
she would just grab and inspire.
Like, she would walk by --
-He told me this backstage.
-The person who was
putting her mic on.
She was like, "Do you like
putting mics on?"
And she was like, "I do." And
she´s like, "Follow your dreams!
But if you ever
stop liking it --
If you ever stop liking it,
you go do something else!"
And I was like, "Wow.
She just really wants to get..."
-That´s her in a nutshell.
-Yeah.
-She inspires
everyone she meets.
-Yeah, she´s wonderful.
-She´s something else.
-And you have never --
This is the first time
that you have played
a real person.
-Yes. Correct.
-So "La La Land," that means,
was not based on a true story.
-It´s not based on a true story.
-None of that happened?
-It didn´t happen.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I have driven a Prius before.
-That´s close enough for me.
-You know?
-So it´s based on a true story?
-It´s based -- It´s loosely
based on a true story.
-What was it --
Did you find it --
Was it extra burdensome
to play somebody who is real?
-I mean, yes, definitely.
It was -- There is a fear factor
that goes into that.
Because she´s going to sit down
and see it at the end.
And, you know, knowing that
is pretty daunting.
Also the fact
that I didn´t play tennis
before playing Billie Jean.
And then when
I went to meet her,
you know,
there was that precedent,
the, like, "Hi, I´m an actress
that´s playing you
that doesn´t play tennis
and I´m super shy."
And she was like, "I´m super
shy. You´re playing me.
You don´t play tennis.
What´s going on?"
-What was the scene when you
first met Billie Jean King?
-I met her at her apartment.
She lives in New York.
And she was so sweet and warm
and inspiring instantly.
You know, she really keys in
on how to inspire you.
So she brought me
up to her apartment,
and her partner, Ilana,
was there
drinking out of a mug that said
"It´s Good To Be King."
-Fantastic.
-And I was like, "It does seem
pretty good to be King."
-Yeah.